I don't even know if I can answer that
today that's so hard oh man I'm out
quick I'm I'm no
[Music]
survivalist Hunger Games is coming back
to theaters which begs the question how
are you going to survive the Hunger
[Music]
Games I mean honestly I would die
immediately knowing me I'll probably die
like in a in an hour I die you're just
giving up right away yeah but you have
like all these Cool Claws yeah they're
paper oh not what you were expecting
spawn Camp get them all the first 10
seconds I would find probably the
nearest tree that has fruit on it and
just wait it out you know I'm just going
to take a nap let everyone else kill
themselves off well I feel like I would
think maybe I could do what pea does and
disguise myself so I just throw a bunch
of leaves on myself and die within the
first 10 minutes we're on agreement in
how to survive just lay down and take it
lay down in high school I had to do
archery and I'm kind of good at
it thank you yeah you have a catniss
everine right here I know I I guess yeah
my strategy would be to run and hide and
I've thought this since I was like what
12 when the first one came out I'd
probably be more of a solo person kind
of doing things stealthy stay in the
shadows you know try to keep quiet try
not get caught no offense but if you
want to stay in the shadows you might
want to pick a better teammate because
uh Carly catches the eye so it's
intimidating so you know maybe you guys
can work something else together man I
would beat all of them I'm black so
yeah if one thing that I don't know is
how to
survive I would definitely sharpen up on
my martial arts skills I like your
confidence yes I have a feeling you're
winning this thing yeah okay my only
tactic would be to make sure that I die
within the first two seconds the torture
would kill me just get it over with
smash my skull in that's a solid
strategy and I hope you take me with
you
[Music]
it's been a while but yes I watched them
when they came out and I'm really
excited about the new one I got dragged
to see Catching Fire and I enjoyed that
one but that's as far as I go with
Hunger Games Catching Fire it it was
nice our favorites well or my favorites
I think Catching Fire is the best
probably what do you think that's my
favorite too yeah the first one feels
more nostalgic cuz it's the first one
but I love Catching Fire that will be
the best booked as well best book best
movie yeah why is it Catching Fire your
favorite I really love Jeffrey uh Wright
and I think he's great in it and I just
I love that Arena best I think it's fun
okay so I feel like y'all would be like
more District than capital is that true
probably I mean I feel like it'd be
weird to say that we're for the capital
I don't know that's kind of like like
Hey we're the fascist people we're the
capital so I mean we all love to think
we'd be team District but maybe there's
a little Capital lean in there I hope
not I don't know
[Music]
I know I'm going to get hate for this
one but I got to go with Harry Potter oh
well that's no who would who would hate
you for that because the people who read
the books are like it's nothing like the
books but you have to realize it's a
book adaptation of course you can add
everything into it and it's consistent
it's great actors great characters great
cinematography everything oh well done
see here everyone I have a feeling I
might know the answer answer so I
suppose we could say Potter yeah I was
actually thinking Jurassic Park now but
uh I mean it is kind of a a Allan Grant
hat you have on so you it can be a Harry
Potter Jurassic Park combo did you guys
read Jurassic Park I did and what's
better the book or the movie The
Ride I don't know cuz I feel like
usually they're not very good but I do
love Pride and Prejudice both as a book
and a film I'm going to say Gatsby Great
Gatsby that's my least favorite book but
yeah nope do not like that movie I mean
we all had to read it in nth grade I
would probably say Cloud Atlas because
the structure of that book was so insane
I was going to say like willly won in
the Chocolate Factory but you just blew
my mind with that The Shining a lot of
people may disagree but I just really
like that one can you give me a here's
Johnny here's
Johnny all the great hor started out as
books Dracula Frankenstein oh it's
anything that's Stephen King honestly I
I like it a lot are you team kids or
team Pennywise kids I'll be team
Pennywise I actually get nightmares and
so I think I like it because that was
one I watched and like woke up five
times with nightmares all night so all
right so if you see a clown in the sewer
and he offers you popcorn what do you
say yeah I'm taking that popcorn I
I I don't think that's the message of
the movie are you taking the popcorn no
good good listen to her I'm trying to
help you out here thanks for tuning in
to this episode of on the street comment
and let us know how are you going to
survive the Hunger Games thanks for
tuning in I'm Mark Ellis we'll see you
next time right here at Rotten Tomatoes
thanks for checking this FD out head
over to rotten tomatoes.com for
everything in the world of movies TV and
in between well my mind is going to
battle royale right now so I mean we
almost just got attacked right there we
better come up with something quick you
all Hunger Games fans I've seen half a
movie you gave up cuz you were bored or
you fall asleep or just had something
else to do my subscription
ended